el vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias
a masterworks más sobre esto en un
momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
los gerifaltes políticos y militares de
china anhelan sobre todo una cosa
reconquistar taiwán a su vez en taiwán
cada vez son más los que sueñan con
lograr una independencia plena y en eeuu
bueno digamos que esperan que algún que
otro traspié le impida a china
convertirse en una superpotencia de
verdad hablamos de un enorme juego de
ajedrez un juego geopolítico en el que
ahora la tormenta de fuego destrucción y
aniquilación que las huestes de putin
han lanzado sobre ucrania ha hecho
saltar todas las alarmas de repente son
muchos los países a lo largo y ancho del
mundo que han entendido una cosa que
incluso en pleno siglo 21 la guerra
puede estar mucho más cerca de lo que
podríamos haber imaginado por supuesto
en todo esto taiwán se lleva la palma
[Música]
la situación geopolítica militar y
estratégica de taiwán tiene muchas
similitudes con ucrania tanto rusia como
china mantienen reivindicaciones que de
una forma u otra pasan por limitar la
soberanía de estos territorios además
tanto taiwán como ucrania son países que
han intentado con mayor o menor éxito
forjar instituciones propias relaciones
con occidente y consolidar un sistema
democrático
pero empecemos por el principio los
taiwaneses empezaron a verle las orejas
al lobo cuando el régimen de xi jinping
terminó de un plumazo con la
independencia que de facto disfrutaba la
antigua ciudad libre de hong kong ese
fue para taipei el primer aviso ahora la
invasión de ucrania ha hecho saltar de
nuevo las alarmas ha sido el segundo y
quizás último aviso
[Música]
y es que veréis durante décadas he dado
por hecho que el ejército popular de
liberación chino no tenía la suficiente
capacidad como para invadir taiwán y
hacerse con el control de la isla sin
embargo según muchos expertos militares
eso podría cambiar muy pronto dados los
planes que china tiene actualmente en
marcha para los años 2025 2027 el
gigante asiático podría estar listo para
lanzar su ofensiva y por eso en taiwán
están prestando mucha pero que muchísima
atención a lo que está ocurriendo en
ucrania la determinación y la
resiliencia que el pueblo de ucrania ha
mostrado a raíz de la invasión rusa ha
inspirado a taiwán reforzando nuestro
compromiso de defender nuestra libertad
viking sao representante de taiwán en
eeuu y ojo que no hablamos sólo de
palabras vacías la brutal invasión rusa
ya ha hecho que el gobierno de taiwán
comience a tomar medidas taiwán busca
extender el servicio militar obligatorio
más allá de los 4 meses el ministro dice
el parlamento que se están considerando
propuestas y que se presentará un plan
este mismo año la presión de pekín sobre
la isla y la guerra de rusia en ucrania
han suscitado un debate sobre cómo
potenciar la defensa bien más allá de
los grandes titulares que elecciones
puede extraer taiwán de ucrania que
puede y qué no puede aprender el país de
chain wind del país de bolo 2012 lentes
que atentos
antes queremos contaros algo interesante
famosos líderes políticos titanes de la
industria ahora más que nunca todos
ellos se están poniendo su dinero en un
activo en particular el arte mientras
que el s p500 lleva un 17 por ciento
abajo desde máximos y el ibex-35 también
está en números rojos a 1 y 5 años vista
el mercado del arte se ha mostrado
resistente de hecho en mayo de 2022 las
casas de subasta han visto precios
récord christie's por ejemplo vendió más
de 800 millones de dólares en tan sólo
siete días y las ventas en sotherby's de
la colección mccloud registraron un
récord total de ventas en 922 millones
de dólares y es que tal y como apuntaba
el responsable global de los servicios
de asesoría en arte y finanzas del city
private bank aún hay mucha demanda de
obras de arte por parte de museos con
renombre en otras palabras que además de
para decorar mansiones el arte puede ser
una herramienta más para proteger tu
patrimonio y de paso oye puedes sacarle
un buen rendimiento así que no nos
sorprende que según deloitte el 85% de
los gestores de patrimonio recomienden
el arte como un activo a incluir en
nuestra cartera y con un nuevo
millonario cada 17 minutos en 2021 la
demanda de obras de alto valor sigue
aumentando así que tenemos una oferta
limitada y una demanda creciente no
parece una mala combinación la pregunta
es cómo podemos aprovecharnos de esta
corriente sin tener que invertir
millones en un solo cuadro con
masterworks puedes incluir obras de alto
valor en tu cartera por una fracción del
coste total porque estabas invirtiendo
la cantidad que elijas en fracciones de
una pintura la verdad que nos parece una
idea revolucionaria y viendo cómo las
obras que han vendido ya han reportado
un 30 por ciento netos de comisiones a
sus miembros parece que además tienen un
buen ojo para seleccionar piezas de arte
por supuesto resultados pasados no
garantizan rendimientos futuros si
quieres dar un vistazo por ti mismo a
masterworks te dejo el link abajo en la
descripción para conseguir además acceso
prioritario y saltarte así la lista de
espera dicho esto continuemos
reacciones desde ucrania
ahora la guerra de ucrania ha servido
para destacar dos ideas primero ha
demostrado que el hecho de ser más
fuerte no siempre garantiza la victoria
militar y segundo que incluso aunque el
país atacante sea toda una potencia
nuclear y un importantísimo proveedor de
suministros clave los aliados
occidentales pueden estar dispuestos a
prestar toda la ayuda necesaria para
armar hasta los dientes a un aliado que
luche para conservar su territorio y su
independencia y ojo que esto era algo
que hasta la invasión rusa de ucrania
generaba muchas dudas y aún más si los
países occidentales se han volcado con
ucrania que básicamente es un exportador
de grano imaginaos qué posición podrían
adoptar con el país que produce más de
la mitad de todos los semiconductores
avanzados que se usan en el mundo y no
lo decimos nosotros lo dice el propio
presidente de los eeuu joe baile baiden
afirma que eeuu intervendría
militarmente si china y madina taiwán
los comentarios durante la visita a
tokio despierta en incertidumbre sobre
si eeuu se está alejando de la política
de la ambigüedad estratégica pero más
allá de eeuu estas son algunas de las
recetas que taiwán puede estar ya
extrayendo la experiencia ucraniana
en primer lugar tenemos que tener en
cuenta que al ser una isla taiwán corre
un elevado riesgo de ser asediada de
hecho antes de lanzar la propia ofensiva
militar es muy probable que china
utilizará una combinación de técnicas de
asedio con acciones de guerra híbrida
como por ejemplo ciberataques o
sabotajes de todo tipo pues bien para
resistir el asedio y en base a la
experiencia de ciudades como mariupol o
jarquín lo primero que tiene que hacer
taiwán es duplicar sus reservas de
petróleo para permitir que el ejército
pueda mantener su operativa
[Música]
actualmente la ley de administración del
petróleo de taiwán prevé que las
reservas de crudo ascienden a 30 días
del consumo medio del año anterior esto
supone aproximadamente un millón de
barriles diarios ahora tras la
experiencia de ucrania los expertos
militares están aconsejando que taiwán
como mínimo duplique esas reservas hasta
los 60 días además este almacenamiento
debería situarse en zonas altas y de
forma dispersa por todo el país tanto
para su protección contra ataques de
precisión como para que el petróleo
pueda seguir transportando se gracias a
la gravedad incluso aunque se produzcan
alteraciones en el suministro eléctrico
también para garantizar el suministro
eléctrico los expertos militares
aconsejan la construcción de múltiples
generadores eléctricos de combustible
junto a los mismos depósitos
asimismo teniendo en cuenta que los
puertos podrían convertirse en objetivos
prioritarios para el invasor el país
debe prepararse para recibir entregas
over the short es decir sin tener que
utilizar las infraestructuras portuarias
en total se estima que estas acciones
podrían costarle a taiwán más de 4.000
millones de dólares pero tener una cosa
clara garantizar la provisión de
petróleo al ejército podría determinar
el rumbo de la guerra de la misma forma
los expertos también están recomendando
que el país incremente urgentemente sus
reservas de alimentos básicos hasta un
mínimo de 120 días de consumo que
construya también pozos de agua por toda
la isla y que ponga en marcha una red
eficaz de internet vía satélite y el
internet starling se convierte en un
salvavidas para los ucranianos en
ucrania en la tecnología de starling ha
encontrado un lugar donde puede
demostrar su valía especialmente si se
usa de forma distinta a la prevista a lo
largo de la invasión rusia ha atacado
constantemente la infraestructura de
comunicaciones de ucrania con armas
militares y ataques cibernéticos la idea
con este primer bloque de medidas sería
preparar a taiwán para resistir el
tiempo suficiente como para que pudiera
llegar la ayuda internacional para que
china tira la toalla pero claro además
de la infraestructura esta meta necesita
sobre todo garantizar una defensa
militar eficaz
[Música]
y justo aquí llegamos a la segunda
lección que nos está dejando la invasión
rusa se puede llegar a contener a un
ejército superior y para hacerlo tenemos
que hablar necesariamente del
equipamiento militar y sobre todo de
tres ejes la defensa balística la
defensa aérea y la defensa marítima y es
que veréis la guerra de ucrania no sólo
está sirviendo de aprendizaje a taiwán
sino también a la propia china por
ejemplo el gigante asiático se podría
haber dado cuenta de que para lograr una
rápida superioridad militar necesitaría
arremeter con una cantidad brutal de
fuego antes de llevar a cabo la invasión
a gran escala esto es algo que rusia no
hizo antes de invadir ucrania pues bien
para poder hacer frente a este más que
probable escenario taiwán tiene que
multiplicar su defensa contra misiles
balísticos y armas de precisión
i
actualmente tengo año tiene programado
actualizar sus 350 misiles patriot pac-3
y comprar 300 interceptores adicionales
probablemente tras la experiencia de
ucrania el esfuerzo sea aún mayor por
ejemplo se podría impulsar la compra de
drones y equipar los con equipamiento de
guerra electrónica lo que permitiría
reducir la precisión de los misiles
guiados chinos esto implicaría para el
invasor un esfuerzo militar y económico
mucho mayor incluso hay quien defiende
en la isla a presionar a los eeuu para
que despliegue su sistema está atenta
igual sin embargo parece poco probable
que en washington estuvieran dispuestos
a hacerlo cuando lo desplegaron en corea
del sur- se produjo un enorme conflicto
diplomático con china
luego ucrania también ha mostrado cómo
impedir que el invasor se haga con el
control aéreo es algo posible y algo que
además puede resultar clave para
ralentizar sus operaciones en esta línea
la defensa ucraniana se ha caracterizado
por estar organizada en capas haciendo
que la potencia invasora no pueda o le
cueste mucho más conseguir la
superioridad aérea sin el control aéreo
china sería incapaz de ejecutar casi
cualquier plan militar contra taiwán
harryhalim jake freyman analistas
geopolíticos pues bien taiwán podría
crear una primera capa defensiva de
mayor alcance y altitud mediante los
patriots una capa media con otras
baterías antiaéreas de menor precisión y
una última capa con sistemas antiaéreos
portátiles es decir los que pueden
transportar consigo los propios soldados
los conocidos como manpads
todos hemos visto en ucrania el ejemplo
de los stinger donados por la otan o los
propios estrellas que ya tenían y que
han servido para derribar numerosos
helicópteros drones o incluso algún que
otro caza ruso por último tenemos el
caso de la defensa marítima por supuesto
al tratarse de una isla este punto cobra
mucha importancia para impedir la
invasión es fundamental que taiwán logre
evitar los desembarcos y que si no
utilice la línea de costa para atacar
posiciones en tierra pues bien aunque
ucrania carecía de una fuerza naval cosa
que taiwán evidentemente si tiene hay
algo que si podría copiar la estrategia
ucraniana de denegación del mar
[Música]
la denegación del mar es un término
militar que implica imposibilitar que el
enemigo utilice el mar para llevar a
cabo un asalto sin que al mismo tiempo
eso implique el control de las aguas
taiwán podría fijarse por ejemplo no
solo como ucrania desplegado numerosas
minas marinas sino sobre todo lo
importante que puede resultar almacenar
y desplegar misiles antibuque y
municiones guiadas de precisión a lo
largo de toda la costa del país en
pequeños depósitos difíciles de detectar
para el inversor
[Música]
de hecho así es como ucrania logró
hundir el mouse back con sus misiles
neptune pasando
desapercibido el buque de guerra moscú
estaba ciego ante el ataque con misiles
ucranianos según un análisis la
tripulación de la rts moscú estaba ciega
y no estaba preparada para el ataque con
misiles ucranianos que hundió el buque
insignia de rusia en el mar negro o de
esa golpeada por misiles mientras
ucrania afirma que ha hundido un segundo
barco ruso además la experiencia en la
guerra de ucrania ha demostrado que el
actual inventario de taiwán podría
resultar claramente
insuficiente e incluso teniendo en
cuenta noticias como esta taiwán más que
duplicará su capacidad de producción
anual de misiles ante las tensiones con
china taiwán planea más que duplicar su
capacidad de producción anual de misiles
a cerca de 500 este año taiwán lleva ya
tiempo mejorando su defensa marítima por
ejemplo con la compra de 400 misiles
antibuque harpoon a eeuu y 25 radares
para poder operar los estos misiles
podrían ser capaces de golpear a los
barcos chinos poco después de que éstos
salieran de puerto pero los números
parecen claramente insuficientes hace
falta más mucho más para tener realmente
una fuerza de disuasión efectiva
en tercer lugar podemos destacar algo en
lo que ucrania literalmente ha aplastado
a rusia la guerra por la narrativa y la
comunicación esto es algo lo que hace
lens que ha demostrado ser todo un
artista si algo ha hecho ucrania ha sido
ganarse la adhesión de la inmensa mayor
parte de occidente si son las víctimas
de la invasión pero eso no quiere decir
que fuera cosa de cantar ucrania se ha
presentado al mundo no solo como la
víctima de una invasión sino también y
sobre todo como un país que lucha por la
democracia la apertura y los valores
europeos esto amigos ha hecho que no
apoyan a ucrania sea de tan mal gusto
que hasta la unión europea se ha puesto
manos a la obra increíble además en todo
momento tenéis que defendió que la
victoria era posible si contaba con el
apoyo de occidente es decir hice una
atribución de responsabilidad pues bien
taiwán es el país con más derechos
civiles de toda asia un líder
tecnológico imprescindible y un
importante aliado occidental fortalecer
la agenda exterior y sobre todo
convertirse en algo así como la meca de
la libertad y los derechos civiles
podría ser clave para llegado el caso
contar con el apoyo masivo y unánime de
occidente es algo de lo que yo soy aquí
en visual político en un pasado vídeo
sobre la defensa de taiwán
[Música]
y por último la cuarta clave que tiene
que ver con la movilización general
sobre todo con las llamadas fuerzas de
defensa territorial que fueron creadas a
partir del año 2015 y que están jugando
un papel clave en la defensa de ucrania
hablamos de una especie de ejército de
apoyo bien organizado y que incluso se
ha constituido como una rama propia de
las fuerzas armadas un ejército que está
compuesto por reservistas y voluntarios
que reciben entrenamiento y que se
encargan de tareas como por ejemplo
controlar la seguridad del territorio
brindarle apoyo logístico las tropas
inteligencia realizar emboscadas y
operaciones de sabotaje o incluso
respaldar ágilmente las propias acciones
de combate del ejército profesional con
efectivos allí donde sea necesario la
idea es que la defensa sea mucho más
densa y por tanto que el invasor tenga
mucho más difícil controlar el
territorio este modelo ucraniano ha
empezado a ser copiado por polonia y
ahora hay quien piensa que taiwán podría
hacer lo propio sin embargo esto podría
llegar a ser muy complicado porque
amigos aquí es cuando entramos en lo que
quizás taiwán no y aprender de ucrania
atentos
[Música]
lo que taiwán quizás no pueda aprender
las fuerzas de defensa territorial han
jugado un papel fundamental en la
resistencia de ucrania y tiene sentido
como os decíamos lograr que la defensa
sea mucho más densa en un territorio
puede convertir una invasión en una
enorme pesadilla al tiempo que el
ejército profesional libera recursos
para poder centrarse en atacar al
enemigo gracias a estas fuerzas ciudades
ucranianas como kif jarquín odessa o
mykolaiv se brindaron hasta el punto que
los soldados rusos no pudieron penetrar
en ellas sin embargo a pesar de su gran
papel esto es algo que quizás taiwán no
pueda copiar
en taiwán si existe un cuerpo de defensa
civil pero lo cierto es que no está
militarizado y que depende enteramente
de la policía hablamos de un cuerpo que
está pensado fundamentalmente para
colaborar en evacuaciones o ante
desastres naturales como terremotos
tifones o inundaciones sus miembros no
reciben ningún tipo de entrenamiento con
armas y desde luego no es probable que
sepan usarlas por sí mismos este es de
hecho uno de los países del mundo con la
legislación más estricta respecto a la
posesión de armas hasta el punto de que
incluso para comprarte una pistola de
pesca submarina necesitas un permiso
policial
y aunque existe el servicio militar este
es muy corto de apenas cuatro meses y
hoy por hoy no brinda un entrenamiento
eficaz ante una situación de guerra el
caso es que además intentar convertir
esta fuerza civil en una especie de
ejército sería algo ilegal vale ya sé lo
que estás pensando pero vamos a ver
alberto eso será tan fácil como ir y
cambiar las leyes y ya está pues no lo
cierto es que no hoy sería ilegal y no
parece existir la voluntad política
suficiente como para cambiar esta
situación al menos así están las cosas
hoy en día pero llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti debería taiwán cambiar
esto y apostar por la resistencia civil
armada debería el país de formosa
construir toda una insurgencia como
hicieron los ucranianos entre 2014 y 222
crees que está igual lograría resistir
una invasión china al menos con tanto
éxito como lo está haciendo ucrania
déjanos tu opinión por aquí abajo en los
comentarios si te gusta este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte a nuestro canal para no
perderte ninguna de las novedades que
están por llegar una vez más gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]